Okay. Uh, if we can begin today,
we have a very special lecture.
I'm very pleased to introduce
Carl Icahn as our lecturer. Uh,
Mr icon has a career that is really,
uh,
relevant to some of the topics we've
talked about in this course. Uh,
one theme we've talked about in
this course is corporate democracy.
And we've talked about a book written
by Burl and means who said that
shareholders are so dispersed that they
have really no control over a company.
And boards of directors are
self perpetuating. Well,
Carl Icahn has made a career of,
uh,
of really opposing that tendency
in American business. Uh,
Carl Icahn graduated from Princeton
University premed in 1957,
a in 1968, he founded
icon and company. Uh,
and this company icon and company has
taken substantial shareholder positions in
a number of major corporations
including Rjr, Nabisco,
Twa, Texaco, Phillips
Petroleum, Time Warner,
a Motorola, uh, and when, uh,
icon and company takes
a position in a company,
it then becomes active in the management
of this company and in changing the way
they do business. And they've
done this with enormous success.
So, uh, Carl, I'm very pleased that
you could come and do this today.
See you,
Bob.
Uh, it would be really nice if you could
give some clues to our students here who
are themselves launching
out on careers of, uh,
how you got started in this and what
your philosophy is and what you would
recommend to them.
The
recovery or you're asking about.
I went down to Wall Street
back in way back in the 60s,
and I thought I was really,
uh, I had gone to Princeton,
a really good school and um, and uh, uh,
I had gotten in there
from a top high school.
I was the first to go for my high school.
Nobody believed I right.
They never took an ivy league.
The Ivy League never took anybody from
this school I went to. But, uh, anyway,
I went,
got in and uh,
left there and I thought I was
real smart guy caught a shot,
went down to Wall Street and a,
worked with Jack Dryfus and I was playing
the market and 1961 and shows how old.
And, uh, in a, in a bull market,
you make a great deal of
money by doing leverage.
It's a little bit like today with all
the leverage that we had and now might be
coming to fruition. But, uh, I was,
I was borrowing money
and bought all these,
could have hurdle of those and I thought
I was a genius and Jack Drivers said,
you're going to lose all your money.
I had made a few bucks playing poker
and that's how I started about eight,
$10,000.
And I made all this
money by borrowing at 90%
and I would go out and make
it a lot more in until weeks.
So my father made it and two years and,
uh,
I saw father said, well, you know,
put some money away. I said, no, Dad,
I'm going to really make a fortune here.
But I went out.
I remember once I bought a Galaxie
convertible, then it was a beautiful car.
I had a beautiful girlfriend. It
was a model. It was pretty nice.
But uh, but uh, uh,
what happened,
the crash came in 1962.
I was wiped out in one day.
I didn't even have the poker winnings lap.
And I tell you, I can't recall, that's a
call left first. So the girl left first,
but it was pretty, it was pretty
close. Maybe just think day,
maybe the same day actually.
And um,
after that I learned and you
have to learn something and uh,
I became an expert in options and um,
after that I built a
following and built a big, uh,
a big following and a big
commission base by yeah,
just learning one area very well.
Probably I knew that area better
than almost anyone on Wall Street to,
not to sound too presumptuous,
but very few people knew it,
so it doesn't mean very much.
But in any event,
I will build up a big
following in 68 boards,
the seat on the stock
exchange with the help of, uh,
one of my uncles and I time I saved a
pretty big amount of money for those days.
And then, uh, I got into
arbitrage but not merger.
Botified and that's something else
you could learn where you can,
where you can do it.
You still do it today,
but it's much tougher
with all these computers.
So I don't do it because I
don't understand the computers
they'd beyond me. So,
uh, I don't, I don't work with them to,
well like being a little
facetious but not too fussy.
So you could buy different convertible
bonds and short the stocks against them.
You had no risk but you
could make a lot of money.
And eventually we did real well
with that and what I do today.
So it's pretty much the same idea.
You buy stocks in a
company that is cheap and,
and you look at the asset value of the
companies that you buy the stocks in and
it becomes a little more complex.
But basically you look for the reason
that they're there. They're really cheap.
And the major reason is often and
usually a very poor management.
So in a sense it's like
an arbitrage can go in,
you buy a lot of stock in a company
and you then try to make changes at the
company. Today. If you read the
newspapers tomorrow, you'll read them.
We're trying to do the
same thing at Motorola.
And if you bothered to read
the Wall Street Journal
tomorrow, or maybe the times,
I don't know, you'll see a little
bit of what we're to do there.
We're trying to get them to change
the structure of the company.
We think the board is very, is
very poor board there. And uh,
we're trying to change what happens.
The other thing about corporate America,
a few people that go to college
where you are now and, and,
and most people in
America don't realize how,
how poorly most of our companies
are run in this country. Uh,
with many exceptions. There's,
they're really very poor.
And when you get inside the
companies, you realize that. And,
and the real reason is
there's no accountability.
There's no corporate democracy. And I've
been staying in that, proselytizing it,
writing about it.
And the reason that we can make so much
money when we go into one of these is,
I'm not even a manager. I never took
a course in management. And, uh, uh,
I wouldn't profess to really know much,
but I don't micromanage.
I put in a very good manager,
they cut the heck out of a cost,
but they changed the
structure of the companies.
And this is the problem in
American today in my opinion,
that we are basically under managed.
We can't compete because the best and
the brightest don't get to be at the top
of the corporate ladder.
And I,
I was sort of a metaphor
that's a little facetious,
but not completely about it.
I call it anti Darwinian.
It's anti Darwinian in
American's corporations and
that means the guy goes to
college and did this and this,
the guy that gets to be the CEO and
he's in college and he's the kind of guy
that, you know, was the
president of the fraternity.
Now all these presidents of
fraternities aren't bad guys,
but basically the normal guy
that I remembered it college was,
he's always there at the fraternity or
the Ed club and he's always had to be
there. If you have a bad day, you walk
over to the club and get feeling bad,
your girlfriend left,
you did bad on a test score or
whatever and you go over there.
He's always there, buys you a
drag and you sit around with him.
He commiserates with,
yeah,
you play a little pool or whatever
and he tells you whatever it is.
Yeah, by girl left me
all, they're all no good.
Usual conversation back and forth.
And what would happen would be your life
again. You can't help it. Like if you do,
just to wonder a little bit when the hell
did he ever do any work. But you know,
he was always there for him
and he never made money waves.
He was never said anything too obtrusive
or we never show too much intelligence.
But he was a good guy.
He goes,
that same guy goes out into
corporate America and he,
he politically, he's a student. He
knows how to get along with you.
And
he never really rocks the boat.
He never comes up with any great ideas.
He's not a threat to a superior.
And as a result,
he moves up the ladder because we,
because they're really
in corporate America,
there's really very little accountability.
And what happens in corporate America,
he moves up that ladder.
There's a good show how to succeed in
business. That was ag many years ago.
That sort of sums it
up. You know, if you say
if a genius has an idea or in corporate
America that junior has an idea,
the next idea is to give
them an idea to resign.
And so he moves along the ladder and he
gets to it and he gets up slowly up to
the top,
I guess too.
He has to a attribute fees likable,
he's politically astute and he used
this survivor and he knows when he's
threatened and it gets to the top.
And this is the attributes of today's
CEOs for the most part with exceptions.
So you know, he doesn't ruffle feathers,
he doesn't get the board of upset.
And as he moves up the ladder,
he finally gets to be
number two to the CEO.
Now the CEO is the same as the same
attributes where he doesn't want to be
threatened and it's violent.
So the CEO will never let anybody be
number two who's smarter than he is.
So by definition,
this the assistant of the CEO,
there's a little dumber than the CEO.
Now there's this guy now is the assistant.
The board likes the CEO eventually
retires and they make this guy,
the CEO, the fraternity president
would talk in a bit. Now he's the,
he's now the head guy to see him and
he'll bring in a number two guy that's a
little dumber than he is because
he doesn't want to be threatened.
So by definition will be run by morons.
I wouldn't pretty soon,
and we're not too far from that right
now, but I'm not from that point in, in,
in our economic history.
And so
this is a problem that we have now.
We've been able to do okay in
this country in pretty well,
even with the fact that were badly managed
because over the last 20 years we've
had a pretty free prewrite we've
gotten from all over the world.
The whole global economy has been booming
and we've been able to get cheap goods.
And these cheap goods kept us from
having inflation. So very simply put,
if you don't have inflation,
it's easy for the Federal Reserve to
keep pumping money into an economy.
So they, so money kept flowing you and
he was throwing up at a punch ball.
The country was at a party and we kept
drinking from this punchbowl enjoying and
the rest of the world
would take out dollars.
They would take our dollars cause
everybody thought, oh America, you know,
it's great. It's a little bit like it
came from some town, you know, and,
and, and there's one family
in the town that, you know,
doesn't do much work, sort of probably
goods, raw wire around the pool,
how fun party and a lot of
the big cars and have the,
the good times and the rest of
the time works hard, you know,
and the farms or wherever they are
and they keep bringing stuff to this.
Rich families have stayed, you know,
they give them whatever they want.
They give him food, they give
them slowly. But you know,
anything in the Bloomberg family just
gives him IOUs and they keep taking the
[inaudible]. So the rich
family, does it do anything,
just lie around the pool and have fun
and travel or whatever and they're,
everybody's working well. One day,
a few of these people are gonna say,
I don't want your IOUs anymore.
You know,
what the hell am I going to take your
eye on users? Worthless cause you to go,
you know you lost all your money.
Well I country think about it is a bit
of not situation we've been given our
audio use,
which are dollar bills to the rest of
the world and taking that cheap goods.
However,
we're reaching a point now where the
dollar as you've been reading, if you're,
if you're, if you're attuned to it,
the dollar's devaluating as we speak.
And we got a, I believe a real
problem on our hands and the economy.
The other thing we've done
in the last five, 10 years,
and I know Bob I'm sure has been talking
to you about this, there's housing.
Housing is like tulip bulbs off they,
they got,
you know,
there was a big crisis in Holland
in the 16 hundreds on tool of bows.
And I like reading about these crises.
It cause everybody bought or what
tool of us, one of the greatest.
The one guy looks and says, Hey, what
the hell am I doing with is to have both.
And all of a sudden he got a crisis.
Well,
and I'm not going to get into
the depth of it, but banks,
because they wanted to make more and
more money and our investment banks,
Wall Street kept issuing
different paper against mortgages.
So it made it simple to give a mortgage.
So these mortgages were given out
to people that couldn't afford them.
And today you have what you call
subprime mortgages, subprime paper.
They issued against his favorite stuff,
go a mortgage back security.
They securitize them.
And these things are all floating around
out and there's maybe about $3 trillion
worth of stuff I'm in all day mortgage
out there. Well, as you've seen,
these haven't produced
prices of confidence and I
don't think we've heard the
last of, and the government sort
of bailed out of the situation.
But I have a JP Morgan takeover,
bear Stearns,
and when I'm not going to
get an a depth of it here,
but it's a real fascinating story.
In any event,
we have a problem of,
of,
of problems in our economy. And, uh,
I think that,
uh,
we are going to see more of these
problems and the next year or so I think,
uh, Bob and talk to you more about
what's going to happen in housing.
But a lot of it depends
on that because if,
if you can't have your
housing prices go back up,
a lot of these pay,
a lot of the people that bought them
can't afford to pay the mortgages,
nor would they want to.
If they see the homes go down in value,
they are going to just say, oh, they're
going to walk away. Now if that happens,
these homes,
other collaterals and the banks for all
these mortgages and we're going to have
and probably do have already a recession.
And that recession could become
a lot more cute because today,
uh, and I'm not going to go, I'm just
gonna open it for questions soon.
But today there is fixed trillion dollars
more of debt in this economy that I
believe that can sustain
because everyone in the middle,
the middle class and
the went on a borrowed,
we'd been shoulder the last few years
to buy these homes. It's a buy for any,
you know, with the credit cards and
go buy anything they felt like buying.
And as a result, I'm not certain that
they can pay that 6 trillion back,
but even if they can,
they're not going to be willing to go buy,
uh, they're not going to
be willing to go buy uh,
more things. So as you, as you have that
happening and you have an inflation,
the earnings of our corporations
will go down and they estimate,
I've talked to one or two very,
a good economist in the last few weeks.
They estimate that earnings of the s
and p averages will go down about 20% of
the next year.
With that,
the stock market is at a,
I would say a precipice.
You don't know which way it's going
to go. So, with all that said,
you have to worry about
about all these things.
And I know you're studying this
and you're learning about it,
but I think there'll be great
opportunities ahead for it. It did.
And the ability for Wall Street who
again to girl dies and buy a lot of,
uh, a lot of these companies,
if you have capitals,
you'll be able to buy these vibes.
So I do tell you that I think
Wall Street is certainly
a good area. If you thinking
about a career, I still
think it's a very good area,
but I, you know, I'm not going to
tell you if you love to writer,
you'll love to play the cello to
go and come to Wall Street. But,
but I do think it's a good career.
I think it makes sense.
I think that corporate
America is learnings from this
and I think we're going to
make our top management much more
accountable in the years ahead.
There were tremendous abuses of
corporate America. Today, a year CEO,
I'll make school a hundred times the what?
The average worker mate.
And he's just simply not worth it.
And the reason you have this is that you,
you have no accountability.
That shell,
the simply don't vote.
They don't care about voting.
And as the whole reason for that,
you like you'll have an incident as dean
relation with the owners of a lot about
stocks,
which are the mutual funds
and institutions that
don't like to vote against
these managers.
However,
someone like myself and a
few other activists do get
a vote now and we do get a
proxy fight going and we'll see,
for instance,
what happens in Motorola's
that we're doing as we speak.
And I think that that will
give an opportunity for
young people like yourselves
to get into corporations in our country.
And
while I think Princeton is the,
might be a little better than Yale,
I think yellow is a good school. And
I think that all of you are, are, uh,
are really, uh, probably
the top, top, top of, of,
of the, of the, uh, of the, uh,
student body in this country
and going ahead in your lives.
I think that the corporations might
be a good blood place to look what,
or Wall Street for that matter,
because I think there's going to
be a need for bright people and,
and I think that you'll be able to be
rewarded for it in the fact that there
will be accountability again.
Well that, well, when I say again,
it never really was accountability.
So I think there will be, uh,
too,
like food,
corporate democracy will have to evolve
so that we can become competitive with
the rest of the world again. So with that,
I'll just basically, I think Bob this,
leave it open to questions and
see if anybody has any comments.
ECON, you were mentioned in, uh, 1962,
you kind of blew up, uh, after that, uh,
entire tobacco and sued. Uh, did. Uh,
how did you regain your confidence?
And I guess most importantly,
how did you regain or gain the
confidence of a future investors?
Well, you're asking a few questions.
I mean, how did gain competence?
I don't think I have a lot of confidence
in my ability to understand what was
going on.
I just learned that you have to really,
really work at something and
understand it. And little by little,
I mean it,
what sort of interest and I'm a sort of
obsessive guy and I work real hard all
my life.
I really get it just topping
and I really delve into it.
And what I came up with was,
uh, a letter there at that time,
the people who stole these options that
were wealthy people across the country.
And it's sort of interesting
that it's not around today,
but they would sell options, calls on
the stock. So if you, so if the, if,
if you're, uh, uh, uh,
someone who traded the market,
you'd like to buy an option on Xyz stock
and wealthier people across the country
would spell these options. We give you
the right today, you have the CPOA,
you know, it's much more computerized.
But then he would do it in the,
over the counter transactions.
And
I was really one of the first to come
in and say to people across the country
rather than to do it with your broker
who doesn't really understand this
business, rather than sell it, sell
it with my teammates. I was a broker,
is telling me, and little by little
people actually answered my ads,
I would put it out of an ad and say,
get to get to see what the true prices
are and what the real value should be for
that option that you're selling through
Merrill Lynch who sell them with nation
those days or whoever.
And we,
I get letters from all over the country
and literally I'd stay down at Wall
Street till midnight calling people in
California that would write in for this,
uh, for this letter. And we built up
a big following because I was really,
uh,
the risk of being modest,
the only real honest guy in that
business because everybody, I mean,
not that they were dishonest,
but you know,
the brokers didn't care and they get
business back from who you sell it to.
I'm not saying that we did anything,
you know, criminal or I'd say,
but nobody really cares to get the
right price for these people. And, and,
and so by getting them the right price,
they would stay with me as customers
for years and years. So we, we, uh, uh,
you know, built it up and built it
up. And then I got one assistant,
then I got another assistant and I,
and I kept,
and I kept moving up the ladder,
but it took a lot of hard
work and perseverance and
that's really where it went
to from there was arbitrage.
And now what I do.
What was the second part of your question?
I forgot.
How did you regain confidence
in your investors and people
who gave money to you?
Uh, did you feel confident
that you could give,
get them to give you money after
you had a kind of wash yourself out?
Well No, I told you that, that we have
that letter and that we were able to, uh,
we were, we were able to
amp to the letter, have the,
I don't know if he heard me because like
I was talking to telling you that we,
uh, we, we, we put the letter out
and then we just gave him a good, uh,
but the thing,
yeah.
Okay. All right. How are you?
Hi,
I'm mark [inaudible] or how are you,
I actually have three questions
for you, but, um, I'll start
with the first one.
I watched the 60 minutes special on you
recently and they try to portray that
there'd been kind of an
evolution in your career. Uh,
they showed some bad press from the 80s
with the TWA deal and then they showed
some good press recently with the so
called icon uplift and some of the
political, I mean the, um, uh, corporate
activism that you've been engaged in.
And in that interview you sort of
insisted that you hadn't changed at all.
And I was just curious if you had changed
and he didn't want to tell a reporter
or if the media was giving you a bad rap,
why can't hear the whole question,
but I haven't changed.
I haven't changed it off.
They call me,
they call me to call you an activist,
you know, I mean, I haven't really, uh,
I think what we do though
is very, uh, it's very, uh,
helpful to all investors.
I mean,
I think that's the point because
when we get into the company,
the stock goes up for everybody.
So it really works out. But, uh,
but I've never changed what I do.
Okay.
Okay. Uh, actually I had
two more questions. Um,
the second question was about China and
there was a special report in the recent
economist talking about the,
a ravenous appetite the China has
for national resources right now.
And I was curious what you thought the,
the effect that would have on global
financial markets and your investing
strategy.
Okay.
Well, yeah, I mean,
giant shiner is, is, uh,
is the great fire of, of,
of low, of, of these commodities. The
trouble with this country is we don't,
we don't have a lot of that.
We don't have a lot of natural resources.
So sell them hanging in the question
really what this country does,
we make software, we make technology.
We were in innovative, but so are they.
So what we really have to do is become a
lot more productive and we have to make
our companies a lot more competitive.
And today I feel we're losing that Ed.
So while China is going
to continue to buy things,
it doesn't mean they're going to buy
them from us. And that's a fairly,
even though the dollar has
gone down a great deal.
Thank you. Uh, this is my last
question. Um, New York Times columnist,
David Brooks gave a great commencement
speech last year at wake forest and he
said he was,
uh,
a journalist who led a boring life
and observed interesting lives,
uh, people like you.
And I was curious. Um,
you mentioned that a lot of
the great people that he'd
met, successful people, um,
had lots of pictures of dead
people on the walls. Uh,
meaning that they had conversations.
He said famous people on pictures
of themselves on the wall,
truly famous people at pictures
of dead people on the walls.
And I was curious if you had any pictures
of great historical figures or what
historical figures inspired you or
influenced you on a regular basis?
Good question. I, uh,
well one of the greatest,
uh,
lots of his I ever read was
Aristotle Nica and ethics.
If you read it and make a, a great, uh,
a great deal of stance where
you live with this golden mean,
but at the end, use
your intellect. I mean,
now you have to really read them in
depth to understand what he's saying.
And then, um, and then there's
a poem by Roger Kipling.
And I like if I'm sure a lot
of you read it, you know,
if you can keep your head about you and
we'll lose him as I read that every once
in a while and,
uh,
in the code that we follow,
that's really important to be able to
meet with triumph and disaster. You know,
and not let either of those imposters
treat those imposters just the same
meaning that if you're doing great,
don't think you're a genius
than if you're doing badly.
Don't think the world comes to an end.
And if you work hard,
if you work hard, maybe south
drive, but if you worked on,
and don't let your ego get ahead of you
with so many people do when you're doing
well, and don't let yourself
become too despondent.
If you're not doing well for awhile,
then I have faith in your own ability,
uh, and, and, and,
and really work hard at whatever you do.
Give it everything you have.
Whether if you can do all that,
I think the chances are that
you're gonna hit a lucky streak.
He goes, luck comes and goes. If you have
your health, what comes and goes. And uh,
realized when you, when you're
doing really well that it's not
just you and then when you're not,
it's not just you either.
So I think that kind of thing.
You should read that poem.
I like the line where it's,
if you can be in a crowd but not
lose the common touch, that's fine.
That's right.
If you could walk in a
crowd and still not lose,
but if you can walk with kings and
that moves the common. Yeah. Okay.
Yup.
I've never walked with Kenzo so I don't
have to worry about losing the common
touch cause I'm not walking with him.
Hmm.
Hi, miss drag on. I have two
questions. My first question is,
to what extent can investors like us
adopt your strategy of buying cheap
unexpecting the value
of a company to go up?
Well, I mean, I don't consider that to
be very lean as strategy. I think that,
uh, when you, when you
buy sampling, the best is,
it sounds simple.
It's not simple.
So by generally when everybody
thinks you're wrong and if it,
and the more people I think you're wrong,
the better you're going
to do it in a long run.
That's how it works.
Because at the end of the day,
when everybody is against you, everybody
sorta stole. You know, so it, it,
it's very hard to do it psychologically,
but
at certain times you're in between and
you're not going to get the benefit of
that. But, uh, the old grave,
a dog philosophy that you,
you should just look at value.
But one of the things is when
people get given up on a company,
that's the perfect dog.
But it,
but it doesn't always work because you
don't have to be damn sure you're right.
I mean,
sometimes everybody is right,
but generally it's not
true that they're right.
Generally if you look at the total,
uh, outlook on a company
and if everybody saw it,
it is down on it.
That's one to look at.
Thank you.
And my second question is,
what in your opinion these days do you
see I was going to do to be successful?
So they need more education,
experience, industry knowledge.
I take,
I think the answer is,
I think the answer is that most of
them have to have to leave the company.
Okay.
But there'll be a little more
good.
You'll be a little more fair
about it. Uh, uh, the, the CEOS
okay.
Uh, have a lot of companies probably
could do a good job, but, um,
they, they, they're more
it into building up. Um,
it's like the royal we,
you know,
it's more like the imperial CEO and they
build up a huge amount of people around
them and they very rarely,
okay,
get to the nub of the problem.
And some of them are probably okay,
probably good guys,
but there's no accountability.
It's like you go to school and you never
have passed and nobody ever bothers you.
And that's what really happens until they
really hit the bad times eight. And, uh,
and I guess you could say I'm
a bad time when I come in.
They don't like it too much,
you know? Uh, uh, uh, uh,
I think that
the problem we have today
is very simplistically,
you don't have true,
so you can't,
it's very hard to get rid of the studio
even though you theoretically have a
boat. It's very hard to
use the boat. I mean,
do you imagine it a political
race that the senator is fighting?
Is the incumbent is fighting for an
election and he can take all the money out
of Washington.
Did he could take it out of the treasury
of the United States and the other guy
can't, you know, and uh, it's completely,
it completely set up and rig for the
CEO because anybody coming in to fight
them, they slew them to begin
with. You know, they, they see it.
They don't see me anymore, too much, cause
they know I'm not going away. But they,
they,
so they do not let a ledger have,
I could go into all the different shark
repellents for all the mud. Um, it's,
it's very,
very difficult to beat one of these guys.
I think that's going to change
in the next four or five years.
That's what I was telling you.
And I think we're going to have a,
a better corporate democracy,
which gives people with real talent
who are really with a work ethic, a,
a chance to really make it.
Mr Icon,
as you've touched upon it,
we may be in the worst credit
bubble in history currently.
If you are right,
the upcoming debt deflation
will be long and painful.
How would you recommend that investors
protect their wealth during this period
to take advantage of upcoming
investment opportunities?
Well, it's, it's all I
do recommend, uh, how,
how do we invest at
this time? I, you know,
it without knowing how
much capital you have, but,
but I would be again,
you know,
I'd been a year at a different arena.
You know,
we invest and we look for these
opportunities now, but, uh,
I feel that, uh, you have to be
certainly very careful, right?
You have to be very careful in your
investment of your investments.
Even though the markets were
going up the last few days,
I would be careful and not have
all your money invested in stocks.
I would look at a lot of
these distressed debt.
Some of the distress
that that has gone down.
I don't know if you understand that,
but some of the,
some of the debt that even even back then,
which was the highest level,
uh, I think is, is there,
is become very cheap.
So that kind of stuff
if something to look at,
but I'd be very careful in
buying equities, but I mean,
you certainly could make a
fortune by, and I'm, I mean, I,
I'm certainly not telling you
it's not going to work, but, uh,
I think it's all risk
reward and a lot of risk.
I wouldn't be looking at
this at the dead areas.
You mentioned, um, about the US
dollar falling in value recently.
What kind of a foreign currency vehicles
or training would you recommend to kind
of hedge your bet against the dollar,
assuming that it continues to fall?
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't know much about carbon seats
and I really don't get into something I
don't know,
something about or generally dog.
So I don't play the currency market
unfortunately because I current,
she's gone down so much and uh,
I,
I don't necessarily think that you
should do that now because it could
theoretically turn in this country,
but I'm only saying that, uh,
that it has become one of the
manifestations of our problems.
The currency of out of the dollar
has the wallet. But do you know,
you can't be that same whine
about everything in Asia either.
Everybody loves Asia now would love
Jina and loves all these countries.
What'd you kind have
some global problems too,
so I don't know that it's time to
rush out of the dollar, you know?
Yeah.
Hi, miss di Com. Why major
criticism that I'm CEO,
I can stomp top right activist says that
they think activists think longterm in
chase of cooperation.
They just want to get money and get out.
How do you answer to that?
I would just say that the,
uh,
that the facts don't bear that out as
far as I'm concerned. I mean if you wee,
I own quite a few companies. Any
company we, we got controller.
I put literally hundreds of
millions of dollars into, I made me,
I bought a company in 85 and rail car
company. We put a hundreds of millions.
We still have the pleat.
I, uh, I kept the,
I bought casinos and energy companies
and over the years kept them,
sold them now,
but that's after 10 years.
So any company that we've been
able to get control of, uh,
I actually kept because getting
control is a great thing. And if you,
if you really believe that
management is not doing well,
you can go and clean them up and put it in
big guy. And so we, uh, we, we, I don't,
I know that criticized you like that,
but that's part of the propaganda machine.
We just not the fast,
um, I related question is that, um,
what do you do when your um,
uh,
activist spirit as now?
I appreciate that as a nutcase.
I Moto roll out when you
ask for a seat in the board,
but just the decline and, well,
well, what's your next step?
All right.
Hm.
You'll have your,
you have a,
you have a patient and now it was a year
later and we'll see what happens now.
But a Motorola is a good example
of what I'm talking about.
People don't like it, they don't
like the cell phone business. But uh,
I really think that that business,
if you look at Motorola and study it,
you're buying that whole
business for nothing.
It's not reflected in the stock price.
And what they have to do,
and I've said it publicly,
is take that business out of Motorola,
spin it off and give
it to the shareholders.
And I think then you've
got a real good value.
So what I'm saying is nobody likes it now,
but hopefully I'm correct on that.
And I really think by
being an activist and,
and putting pressure on that board
that has done nothing really,
that I think eventually that will happen.
Hopefully.
Maybe we'll have one
or two more questions.
Yeah.
Two more questions and then we'll wrap up.
Okay.
Mr Icon,
why does the United States have bad
corporate governance and which countries
have better models?
All right.
We got bad corporate governance.
It's evolved into this.
I don't think that why she
didn't understand how bad it is.
Nobody's really focused on it.
The different states,
the way we structured
the different states,
one corporations to to register it and
therefore what the rules are such that
they protect the corporation with the
poison pills and I can't get into all
these different things.
Staggered boards, poison pills,
and I think if you just change some of
that, we could be like for instance,
England as much better.
Canada has much better where you could
without getting too detailed and simple
by this where you can't have two or
elections and the United States because
of the way they're structured in the
stage, you know the division between
the federal and the state government,
the have not been able to
really Patel some of the abuses.
But I think it will of
course sooner or later,
especially to have a bad recession.
You mentioned that you believe that
many companies are poorly managed.
Obviously you don't
invest in every company.
So I was wondering what factors you look
for in identifying companies that you
want to invest in and that you
think are especially poorly managed.
Okay. We look at a lot of
company, it's obviously,
I have a whole group of people here that
do that and I have a bunch of lawyers
that look at all the providence and lead
companies and their bylaws and their
charters. But really some of them
become very apparent. And when
you look at them, you can,
you can understand and you have to
see that it related to the economy.
But some of these companies, uh,
it's just the parents that, uh,
the value of these companies
would be much better if,
if they were, if they
were better run, well,
they just simply did certain
things like, you know, like,
like borrows examples later that
broke it off or he, you know,
and then some biotech companies
that we're involved in now,
there's a need to them by the big Pharma,
big Pharma.
It hasn't really done
research for years for many,
many marriages in the biotech area.
And therefore a biotech
companies are that well run.
But they do. They have spent a great
deal in research for, you know, uh,
the large molecule drugs and, and,
and so therefore,
you look at the [inaudible],
some of them become
quite apparent African.
You're doing it for the years and years.
I've known him a lot of,
it's almost after you do all the work,
it's almost an inch thick, you know,
a there which could be at a
monitor too fast. You know, it's,
it's like asking some real
great tennis way. Well,
why did you move here instead of,
there are four core player, you know,
when you're running down the field,
why didn't you go to this way
instead of that way when you're,
when you're running down the field.
And I don't think you could tell you it's
just one of an instinct why you do it.
But that's after a lot of work on,
well, I think this has been a
very, uh, enlightening talk. Uh,
and Carl,
I want to thank you very much.
Thank you.